so we're here at London Film on
comic-con it's lovely to see you here
Billy have you enjoying it so far um I'm
really enjoying it I I mean it's it's
been quite back-to-back it's quite a
full-on day but I've met some lovely
people and actually seen some people
I've met at previous signings which is
quite funny and you know it's sweet see
their dedication really so how does it
feel returning to Doctor Who for the
50th anniversary special I'm just
looking forward to the fans being able
to finally see it really because there's
so many questions relentless questioning
about what it's about to happen and I
can't say anything so we nice speaking
rid of this burden of that enormous
secret and it's a Ritz like a gift to
the fans really the 50th isn't it so
it's just all in all it's I think it's
pretty exciting how did it feel
returning to Doctor Who because
obviously it's been a little bit of a
while I I know I never feel that anxious
about returning because I've I'm friends
with a lot of people I've built some
really good relationships and I always
know that it's going to be beautifully
written so it's I think you kind of
anxious in the first on the first day
and in terms of
you know kind of getting back into the
character and whether you've actually
still got it there and she no means
otherwise it's it's pretty a pretty
seamless and enjoyable the occasion like
working with of course David again but
also matter who you have work with
before haven't you yeah Matt's a really
good friend of mine so and dave is a
really good friend of mine so it was
quite funny being on set with both of
them and having to talk to both you okay
not leaving anyone else irineu said it's
gonna be nice to kind of lay to rest any
rumors and search about a speculation
about the show when we finally get to
see the fifties which is so looking
forward to but what's the favorite kind
of way out there rumor that you've heard
in the time when people have been saying
whoa what could happen on the fiftieth I
haven't heard any rumors if I'm honest I
think when you're when you don't do
Doctor Who as frequently or as often as
David and Matt or you know whoever is
currently in it it's not a massive part
of your life and so I'm not I'm not on
that kind of tittle-tattle thread
anymore so I don't know what people to
say and there's something quite
relieving about that because the
speculations nothing worse than
speculation speculation I mean gosh you
just come off the back of an enormous
speculation for who was gonna be the
next doctor after Matt left of course
obviously we know now a brilliant
computer Capaldi but I mean you were
also one of the names he was on bookie
the lists as possibly being the new
incarnation of the doctor what did that
feel like I said I I think it was
inevitable that they were going you know
they kind of anyone who's ever been in
it they I say think they seemed think
that they were the next incarnation you
know I mean people talked about it spoke
about it so much you start thinking
maybe I I am the next dog
maybe I just have they just haven't made
that cool but maybe that's their
intention but I I think it's such a hard
job I'm obviously now I've got found me
I think even if I I didn't know I think
I'd find it really hard to do it's a lot
of work and it's a big responsibility
and I'm not sure I'd want it do you
think about the choice of Peter Capaldi
and the leaves I think it's brilliant
I've always really loved him I really
admired him I think he's a brilliant
actor he's both absolutely terrifying
and incredible with comedy and I really
like the fact that he's a bit older you
know I think would be it will open up a
whole new set of of fans and I think
it's it makes absolute sense it's a
really wise choice finally what we can
look forward to for you next Billy no
just about to start filming I think
called penny dreadful and we film that I
start working about a couple of weeks we
film that in Dublin and that's hopefully
going to be the next couple of years of
my life so what's that about
it's really hard to sit to say what it's
about because it's it's about it's about
so many things and unfortunately we only
we only get one script at a time really
but it has kind of supernatural elements
versus all of these kind of entwined
with these great iconic figures in in
literature and and I think at the heart
it's a lot about people trying to work
out who they are
who do play I'm playing a girl called
Brona Croft we look forward to much more
excitement on that and thank you so much
for chatting to us
you